Sidney Blumenthal the old figure from
the Clinton scandals of the 90s is back
in the nose
all signs are pointing to the conclusion
that Hillary's political hitman with
that pageboy haircut was a likely source
for the infamous steel dossier when you
hear who the source one of the sources
of that information is you're going to
think oh my gosh I've heard that name
somewhere before where could it possibly
have been and find source the domestic
source and I'm trying to think how
Secretary Clinton to find him I think
she said he was an old friend who
emailed her from time to time I'd be
really warm if your warm yeah
now recall that Sidney Blumenthal once a
lefty journalist for the Washington Post
and The New Republic worked alongside
his old pal Paul Begala
in the Clinton White House hired in 1997
Blumenthal and begala were the two-man
bomb squad committed to smearing and
slimming anyone who was making life
difficult for the President and mrs.
Clinton Sid was a prime grand jury
witness during the Monica Lewinsky
scandal and is credited with leaking
nasty stories to the press at the time
to defile the reputation of special
prosecutor Ken Starr hold on to that
thought Blumenthal affectionately known
by his foes as Sid Vicious and not for
his love of punk rock was one of
Hillary's most loyal enablers in
fiercest attack dogs as the ultimate
Washington insider he climbed on to the
Clintons in his association with them
became the meal ticket that never ran
out kind of think of it this way like a
maggot on a piece of rotten carrion
except nastier now when it comes to the
phony steel dossier I always knew
something seemed odd that the Clintons
had more to do with it than just paying
for it one of her old henchmen might
even be behind some of this most lurid
details now Blumenthal managed to land
the Nifty role of advising Hillary
when she was at the State Department and
getting $10,000 a month as a consultant
for the Clinton Foundation now what did
he do for that ten grand a month
he provided something called mission
message guidance I'll bet in emails
reported on by the New York Times
we learned that Blumenthal funneled
advice to Secretary Clinton about things
such as Libya now not because he had any
unique experience on North African
affairs but because a friend of his
wanted to do business there what a guy
now fast forward to the present day the
Grassley Graham criminal referral
contains this one memorandum by mr.
Steele that was not published by
BuzzFeed is dated October 19 2016 it
states that his company quote received
this report from redacted US State
Department that the report was the
second in a series and that the report
was information that came from a foreign
subsys who quote is in touch with
redacted a contact of redacted a friend
of the Clintons
who passed it to redacted it is
troubling enough that the Clinton
campaign funded mr. Steele's work but
that these Clinton associates were
contemporaneously feeding mr. Steele
allegations raises additional concerns
about his credibility now this is
important because we had been led to
believe that Steele's dossier is sources
for that infamous mess were Russian well
it turns out that they may have been
Clinton black ops law specialists
laundering information to steal through
the Obama State Department wild now who
might those Clinton associates be last
month senators Grassley and Graham sent
letters out to the DNC asking them to
produce any communications they had with
Sidney Blumenthal and Cody Shearer
between March 2016
in January 2017 now let's get to share
in a moment but this is where the plot
thickens now assuming Grassley and
Graham's allegations are true Blumenthal
and Cody Shearer
may be responsible for the nasty
salacious claims against Trump in that
dossier it certainly would fit their
profile now Blumenthal is a smear artist
extraordinaire and his sidekick Cody
Shearer is a longtime Clinton ally known
to them as mr. fixer and the words of
the Weekly Standard Shearer is one of
the most disreputable characters in
Washington he last turned up in a Pro
Publica report in 2015 about Sidney
Blumenthal hacked emails now those
emails revealed that Shearer get this
was running a quote secret spy network
that fed Hillary Clinton information on
Libya and Benghazi when she was
Secretary of State
so he had been back channeling
information to the Obama State
Department for a long time now if these
allegations that Blumenthal and Shearer
were at least some of Steel sources for
that dossier if that proves true the
Clinton's fingerprints their closest
associates their hitmen fixers are all
over this thing they funded the creation
of the fake dossier and then mrs.
Clinton's parasitic proxies fed
information to Christopher steel with
one objective destroy Donald Trump by
any means necessary and that's the angle